let's say that both Ben's shoes and
Jason's shoes are publicly traded
companies and that's all that all that
means is that both of their shares are
traded on exchanges maybe it's the the
Nasdaq or the New York Stock Exchange or
some other exchange and the going price
on those exchanges the last closing
price for Ben's stock was 2150 per share
the last closing price for Jason's stock
is $12 per share what I wanted to
explore in this video and probably the
next view is what is that saying for
what the market thinks these businesses
are worth so in both of these situations
they have 10,000 shares and remember the
shares are a split of the owners equity
it's not a split of the assets it's a
split of just the equity part right over
here so if shareholders are willing to
pay 2150 per share for Ben's stock and
there are 10,000 shares in Ben's company
so you take 2150 times I'll do it this
way times 10,000 times 10,000 shares
gives us a market cap so 21 about 2150
times 10,000 gives us two hundred and
ten thousand two hundred actually two
hundred and fifteen thousand two hundred
and fifteen thousand dollars and what
this says is look if each of those each
of those ten thousand slices of the
equity is worth 2150 then the entire
equity portion is going to be the market
is valuing it at two hundred and fifteen
thousand dollars and this calculation
this multiplication of the market price
per share times the number of shares
this is called the market cap the market
cap short for market capitalization the
market cap of the company and all it is
is what is the market valuing the equity
part of Ben's company worth let's do the
same thing for Jason's company you have
$12 per share so you have $12 per share
times times 10,000 shares times 10
10,000 shares that gives us a hundred
and twenty thousand dollar market cap so
the market is telling us
the market is telling us that even
though on the books Ben's equity is
based on how he valued his assets in his
liabilities 135,000 the market is
actually valuing this at two hundred and
fifteen thousand and in the next video
we'll we'll think about what that means
for how the market is actually valuing
the business in the case of Jason's
business this instead of a thirty five
thousand dollars of equity just straight
up from what's on the books the market
is valuing this piece right here at one
hundred and twenty thousand dollars so
hopefully that gives you a little sense
of what one what shares are a share of
their share of the owner's equity an out
of the assets and it also gives you a
good sense of what market cap is it's
the markets value of the owner's equity
and notice in both cases and it's
usually the case it's going to be a
different number than the book value the
number that's actually on the books